Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Heute mit einer Sonderausgabe zum Rasenfunk-Jahr 2020. Was ist alles passiert? Was tut sich bei uns? Und eine große Entscheidung steht an. Das alles jetzt im Rasenfunk. Und ich begrüße bei mir the one and only, the one and only Frank Helmschrodt, der Ed Helmi. Wir haben heute ein Tribünengespräch im Gewand eines Kurzpasses vor uns. Wir wollen aufs Jahr 2020 zurückblicken. Was wir gerne im Rasenfunk Royale machen, den gibt es aus Gründen jetzt noch nicht, weil wir haben ja noch gar nicht die Hinrunde fertig gespielt. Und auch insgesamt wäre ein bisschen wenig Zeit, den zu hören. Deswegen machen wir das jetzt. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass du mit dabei bist. Was erwartet euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da draußen? Eine pickepackevolle Sendung, um andere Formate zu zitieren. Wir wollen mit euch erst kurz ein bisschen inhaltlich auf das Rasenfunk-Jahr zurückblicken. Was ist jetzt eigentlich in diesem besonderen Jahr 2020 bei uns passiert? Wir wollen euch auch einen Blick geben, wie hat sich die Unterstützung des Rasenfunks verändert? Wie ist da der aktuelle Stand? Wie zufrieden können wir damit sein? Wir werden natürlich auch über den Kiosk reden. Wir werden, Franks Keller wird wieder vorkommen in dieser Folge. Aber, kleiner Spoiler, vielleicht zum letzten Mal. Dann können wir noch auf 11 Leben blicken. Was hat das eigentlich auch für den Rasenfunk bedeutet? Und vielleicht gibt es da ja, da übernimmt einfach Frank die Moderation und ich antworte auf was immer Frank mir da hinweist. Und dann gibt es einen ganz wichtigen Part, bei dem uns wichtig wäre, dass ihr den auch hört. Das heißt, wenn ihr sagt, ah, Inhalt des Rasenfunkes ist mir völlig egal, habe ich doch jede Sekunde gehört, dann springt bitte auf jeden Fall zum letzten Kapitel in dieser Folge, nämlich wir nennen es Rasenfunk 2021. Wir haben einige Überlegungen, die das nächste Jahr betreffen und wir haben vor allem eine Umfrage, die euch beteiligt, die uns sehr wichtig ist in diesem Zusammenhang. Diese Umfrage werdet ihr in den Show Notes finden. Ich vermute aber oder gehe davon aus, dass es auch sinnvoll ist vorher zu hören, was wir eigentlich zu sagen hatten. Und dann die Umfrage auszufüllen. Das wäre uns sehr wichtig, dass ihr da mitmacht, weil da einige große Entscheidungen für uns anstehen oder zumindest an die Tür klopfen. Deshalb, wenn euch der ganze andere Rest nicht interessiert, hört bitte den letzten Part und beteiligt euch an der Umfrage. Das war die Begrüßung in Ankündigung. Jetzt ist mir gerade eingefallen, das wird dann der erste Kurzpass seit langem wieder mit Kapitelmarken. Die spar ich mir ja eigentlich im Kurzpass.
Ja, ich habe gerade mal um deiner Zahlenliebe einigermaßen gerecht zu werden.
Ich glaube, wir haben beide dieselbe Seite offen.
Wenn ich mal großzügig den Dezember abziehe, wo ja jetzt schon ein bisschen was über Global Tactics lief, dann waren es so ca. 1200 Bestellungen, die wir bearbeitet haben, seit der Eröffnung des Rasenfunk.
Die du bearbeitet hast, Frank. Ich war immer kurz mit dabei.
Du sagst ja in der Schlusskonferenz auch immer wir, obwohl eigentlich du nur von dir sprichst. Insofern passt schon wir. Also 1200 Bestellungen auf jeden Fall. Sprich, stimmt das überhaupt? Mir kommt so wenig vor.
Nee, stimmt. Wir sind beide, glaube ich, exakt auf derselben Seite.
Das waren die starken Schwankungen. Die ist sehr genau. Weil 1200 Bestellungen sind ja nur 100 im Monat. Bei 12 Monaten. Aber es waren eben auch Monate dabei mit weniger. Dafür einige mit viel mehr.
Genau. Auch hier im Bereich des Kiosks tassen wir uns ja noch heran. Also nicht nur finanziell haben wir ja schon ein bisschen abgefangen, sondern auch eben von der Frage, wie viele Produkte sind eigentlich genügend Produkte? Also das war ja auch ein Teil der Frage, kauft man sich noch eine zweite Rasenfunktasse, wenn man schon eine hat? Egal, wie schön sie vielleicht ist oder wie wichtig die Botschaft, die da drauf steht. Wir tasten uns daran. Wir werden jetzt auch nicht den Kiosk fluten mit Dingen, weil wir ja alles vorfinanzieren müssen. Da könnt ihr euch sicher sein. Aber ich glaube, jetzt haben wir zumindest andere Möglichkeiten und werden hoffentlich diese Ausfallmonate, die es in diesem Jahr gab, wo einfach keine Tassen im Shop waren und Tassen sind der wichtigste Gegenstand, der von euch da draußen gekauft wird, das wird jetzt hoffentlich im nächsten Jahr nicht mehr passieren. Und dann entwickelt sich der Kiosk hoffentlich weiter. Das war jetzt ein sehr schöner Start, ein anstrengender Start. Wir haben unglaublich viel gelernt, was alle Belange von dem Betreiben eines Kiosks angeht. Und jetzt im nächsten Jahr ist dann hoffentlich das Jahr, in dem das Ganze sich so positiv weiterentwickelt, dass auch die positiven Effekte dafür für alle Seiten noch deutlicher spürbar werden. Sowohl für euch da draußen, die ihr hoffentlich immer noch Lust habt auf Sachen vom Rasenfunk, als auch für uns und für alle anderen, die daran beteiligt sind. Wir versuchen ja auch in diesem Bereich jedem, der uns, also Mani und Tobi, die uns bisher die Designs gemacht haben, die sollen dafür gerecht entlohnt werden. Global Tactics soll für den Versand gerecht entlohnt werden. Die ganze Lieferkette soll, so weit wir es beeinflussen können, davon profitieren. Und wenn dann der Kiosk im Gesamten wächst, dann haben wir was davon, aber auch alle anderen, die daran beteiligt sind. Und das ist, denke ich, so ein bisschen unsere Resolution fürs nächste Jahr, was den Kiosk betrifft. Hoffentlich können wir da einfach aufs nächste Level zusteuern.
Definitiv. Und wenn ihr irgendeine Form von Feedback habt, speziell zum Kiosk, schreibt mir gerne Mail an kiosketrasenfunk.de. Ich hab da immer ein offenes Ohr für Kritik oder Lob. Lobhudelei muss tatsächlich nicht sein, aber wenn euch wichtige Produkte fehlen oder ihr vielleicht was zu bemängeln habt an dem bisherigen, aber euch bisher nicht getraut habt, traut euch ruhig. Wir hören gerne auch negative, also natürlich hören wir nicht gerne negative Dinge, aber wir nehmen negatives Feedback auch gerne auf, was uns eben hilft. Nur so können wir besser werden. Und gerne immer her damit kiosketrasenfunk.de.
Sehr gut. Auch gerne zur Präsentation der Produkte. Wir machen das ja so ein bisschen witzig und reduziert, aber schreibt uns da gerne, wie ihr das gerne hättet. Und Produktwünsche sehr gerne an kiosketrasenfunk.de. Wir müssen ja bald die Entscheidungen treffen, was jetzt eigentlich so die nächsten Dinge sind, die wir angehen. Vielleicht kommt ja doch noch der Rasenfunk-Käsehobel. Das ist ein kleiner Favorit von mir, hab ich dir noch gar nicht erzählt. Ja, eine wahnsinnig tolle Idee. Ich freu mich davon, schon wieder 1000 im Lager zu haben oder 300. Und dann liegen da von 280 einfach rum. Na gut, vielleicht springen wir dann in den nächsten Themenkomplex. Du darfst zum Moderator werden, wenn du möchtest. Wir dachten...
Es geht um elf Leben.
Es gehört ja irgendwie zu diesem Jahr mit dazu.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz die abholen, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer dieses Thema komplett versäumt haben. Max, mach doch mal kurz einen Elevator-Pitch für elf Leben.
Elf Leben ist der Podcast, an dem ich seit drei Jahren jetzt arbeite und der in diesem Jahr endlich erschienen ist, in dem ich die Geschichte von Uli Hoeneß aufarbeite mit vielen Gesprächspartnern und Partnerinnen und anhand der Biografie von Uli Hoeneß auch die Geschichte des deutschen Fußballs, ein bisschen auch der deutschen Gesellschaftsversuche nachzuerzählen und an diesem Projekt saß ich schon eben vor drei Jahren, buchstäblich. Ich kann, und wir zwei haben damals auch schon darüber gesprochen und es ist aber in diesem Jahr erst endlich online gegangen und es ist aber neben dem Rasenfunk, es ist, ich habe mehr Zeit in Elfleben gesteckt als in den Rasenfunk und das muss man erst mal schaffen, weil man weiß, wie aufwendiger die Vorbereitung von Sendungen vom Rasenfunk ist. Es ist das dominante Thema für mich in diesem Jahr gewesen und seitdem eben die erste Folge erschienen ist, nämlich Anfang September, seitdem kann ich jetzt auch endlich darüber sprechen, dass ich die ganze Zeit an Elfleben arbeite, weil wir aus verschiedenen Gründen das ja immer so ein bisschen im Verborgenen gehalten. Es war immer dieses Projekt, was noch so mitlief. Irgendwann habe ich angefangen es kryptisch anzukündigen. Jetzt wissen wenigstens alle, warum ich Tag und Nacht arbeite und noch kein Ende in Sicht ist. Das liegt eben einfach an Elfleben und das hatte dann eben auch indirekt Auswirkungen auf den Rasenfunk und ehrlicherweise ein bisschen mehr, als wir beide das antizipiert hatten vor diesem Jahr.
Wir haben das ja gerade schon ein bisschen mit erwähnt, dass es um den Rasenfunk in diesem Jahr ging. Wie da das so ein bisschen der Einfluss im Vorfeld war. Was würdest du denn sagen, wie war denn der Einfluss auf den Rasenfunk jetzt nach dem Elfleben öffentlich? Siehst du da überhaupt irgendeinen Einfluss?
Meinst du von den Hörerzahlen und der Bekanntheit?
Na ja, ganz generell. Wie betrifft es den Rasenfunk überhaupt, dass es Elfleben gibt?
Ja, ganz hart. Natürlich zum einen hinsichtlich des Outputs. Also die internationalen Kurzpässe, die ich selber so gerne habe, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber ich kann sie einfach derzeit nicht leisten, weil das im Grunde immer ein Vormittag ist, der mir in der Woche fehlt. So ein Kurzpass, bis er dann doch veröffentlicht ist. Und alles dauert dann doch immer einen Vormittag. Die Kurzpässe kamen nicht mehr. Tribüngengespräche, immerhin vier haben wir geschafft, aber mehr nicht in diesem Jahr. Und ich meine, du kennst ja mal eine Liste an offenen Tribüngengesprächen, die zum Teil auch schon fast ausrecherchiert sind, die eigentlich nur noch umgesetzt werden müssten, nur noch in Anführungszeichen. Also in diesem Sinne hat es den Rasenfunk betroffen, dass eben unser Mein-Output im Rasenfunk zurückgegangen ist. Und zwar auch mehr, als ich es eigentlich erhofft hatte. Ich glaube, es gibt aber auch viele positive Dinge, die für den Rasenfunk dabei runterfallen. Also nicht nur, dass schon das Feedback eigentlich aller Hörerinnen und Hörer, die vom Rasenfunk dann auch in 11 Leben rein gehört haben, war, dass es ihnen gefallen hat. Also ich habe, glaube ich, in meinem Leben noch nichts gemacht, was so viel positive Resonanz hervorgerufen hat. Also sprich, jeder, der den Rasenfunk hört, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass euch 11 Leben gefällt, die ist zumindest meiner empirischen Wahrnehmung nach sehr, sehr hoch. Und das ist natürlich was. Also man hat quasi einen Rasenfunk nur mit einem anderen Thema bekommen. Und das geht auch nicht so krass über... Also es ist auch für nicht-Uli Hoeneß-Fans und für nicht-Bayern-Fans sehr gut hörbar. Nachdem ich da jetzt so viele Rückmeldungen bekommen habe, traue ich mich das jetzt einfach so zu sagen. Das ist natürlich der eine.
Und vor allem sogar für nicht-Fußball-Fans.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also ich, bestes Beispiel, ich kann es ja jetzt sagen, damals durfte ich noch nicht so richtig, dass ich die ersten fünf Folgen auf dem Weg in den Urlaub gehört habe, die ich von dir so als Preview bekommen habe, als erster Feedback. Es lief dann im Auto und meine Frau, ich habe eigentlich befürchtet, dass meine Frau nach zehn Minuten sagt, komm, können wir irgendwie was anderes hören als Fußball? Weil die sich für Fußball so gar nicht interessiert. Aber die hat gesagt, lass ruhig laufen. Und dann liefen die ersten fünf Folgen auf zwei längeren Autofahrten.
Ach, wie cool. Das freut mich immer noch. Und das ist aber auch das Feedback, das ich bekomme. Also von vielen Leuten, die eben sagen, sie verstehen jetzt dann den Fußball. Und das ist durchaus einer der positiven Effekte auch für den Rasenfunk. Ich dachte immer, ich hätte Ahnung von der Entwicklung der Fußball-Bundesliga und wie sie auch so ein bisschen sich in die deutsche Geschichte einfügt. Und oh boy, was I wrong? Ich wusste gar nichts. Ich war wie Jon Snow. Und ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt alles weiß. Das wäre völlig vermessen. Aber ich habe das viel, viel besser für mich sortiert bekommen. Ich weiß auch jetzt viel besser, warum ich manchmal ein Problem mit dem Fußball habe, mit dem Auftreten des Fußballs. Die ökonomischen Rahmenbedingungen des Fußballs, für die ich mich immer schon interessiert habe. Da habe ich nochmal wirklich einen großen Fundus dazu gewonnen, wie sich das eigentlich entwickelt hat. Woher zum Beispiel die Schuldenbeträge kommen, die die Vereine heute haben. Dass sie die im Grunde seit den 80ern mitschleppen und in den 90ern, als dann die Zahlen explodiert sind, aufgrund verschiedener Faktoren nicht genutzt haben, um die Schuldenlast wesentlich abzubauen. Also das Wissen und die Tiefe, in der ich mich mit Fußball befasst habe, das hat mit F-Leben ein neues Level erreicht. Und das wird man auch im Rasenfunk merken. Vielleicht merkt man es jetzt schon manchmal an Dingen, wie ich über Dinge rede und nicht rede. Und das wird aber auch in der Zukunft, glaube ich, einen positiven Effekt haben, weil es grundsätzlich, glaube ich, einfach nicht schlecht ist, in diesem Thema tief drin zu sein, wenn man drüber spricht. Und allein das hat sich für F-Leben verändert. Plus, dass ich über F-Leben gelernt habe, es ist dann doch gar nicht so schwer, an auch bekanntere Fußball-Persönlichkeiten heranzutreten. Also ich war erstaunt, wie viele Nummern ich zum Teil sogar im Telefonbuch hatte, weil du, Frank, du würdest es nicht glauben, wie oft ich gedacht habe, ich könnte doch mal XY anfragen.
Das überrascht mich tatsächlich.
Ja, das hat auch damit zu tun, dass ich mal so einen Teil eines Telefonbuches zugeschoben bekommen habe. Das heißt, es waren nicht nur Nummern, die ich selbst abgespeichert habe, aber zum Teil waren da noch alte Kontakte aus Freundezeiten drin, die ich damals mal hatte. Und ich dachte mir so, ach krass, warum habe ich den eigentlich noch nie angerufen? Und das wird man auch im Rasenfunk merken. Dass wir, glaube ich, zum einen eine andere Wahrnehmung haben. Also in dem Fall jetzt ich als Person. Also das merke ich jetzt schon, dass das Elfleben auch von Menschen gehört wird, die den Rasenfunk noch überhaupt nicht kannten und vielleicht auch mit dem Rasenfunk als solches dann gar nicht so viel anfangen können. Aber die Elfleben mögen und die damit aber auch dann besser verstehen, was es bedeutet, wenn ich für ein Interview anfrage. Also das muss man sich ja klarmachen. Vielleicht dazu eine kleine Anekdote. Ich hatte jetzt einen... Ach komm, ich kann es schon sagen. Eigentlich ist es ja egal. Jetzt muss ich ja nicht mal immer so mysteriös sein. Ich habe Andy Herzog interviewt. Jetzt am Freitag war das. Und wenn du einen Spieler, einen ehemaligen Spieler anfragst und sagst, ich würde gerne ein Interview mit denen machen, um dieses Thema soll es gehen, dann ist die Antwort im Grunde fast immer ja, okay, 20 Minuten kriegen sie. Das ist die erste Reaktion, die du in der Regel von ehemaligen Fußballprofis bekommst. Und die meinen das nicht böse.
Kommt die dann vom Profi direkt in der Regel?
Sehr, sehr unterschiedlich. Wenn da ein Manager dazwischen hängt, dann wird alles komplizierter, das kann ich schon mal sagen. Dann kriegst du auch eher eine Absage. Die größere Chance ist immer, wenn ich einen direkten Kontakt habe, weil ich dann auch besser erklären kann, was ich eigentlich mache. Aber mit Andi Herzog hatte ich 15 Minuten Interview. Und weil es Andi Herzog ist, ist da trotzdem was rausgekommen, was ich auch für Elfleben verwenden kann. Aber da seht ihr, wie weit die Lebensrealität von Fußballprofis im Umgang mit Interviewanfragen vom Rasenfunk entfernt ist. Denn mit 15 Minuten kann ich kein Interview sprechen machen. Aber gleichzeitig ist das für ihn eine völlig normale Zeit für die Dauer einer Anfrage. Er hat viele andere Dinge zu tun. In der Regel fragen ihn Journalisten an, die Zitate aus diesem Gespräch verwenden wollen. Für die reichen auch 15 Minuten, wenn du ein 15-Minuten-Gespräch gut vorbereitest. Und Andi Herzog ist dann auch wie ein Automat, in dem man eine Wünsche wirft. Also er braucht auch keine Zeit, um warm zu laufen. War fantastisch. Selten so gute 15-Minuten-Interviews gehabt. Aber das ist quasi deren Lebensrealität. Und dann erklärt sich natürlich sehr schnell, warum der Rasenfunk Probleme hat, wenn er solche Spiele anfragt und sagt, ich hätte sie gerne für, naja, zwei Stunden bräuchten wir schon. Besser wären ehrlich gesagt drei. Also könnten sie sich vielleicht keinen weiteren Termin auf den Termin legen. Das ist, das klingt für die völlig absurd. Das klingt für die auch völlig maßlos. Das klingt für die, als würde ich als Kaiser von China bei ihnen... Wobei eigentlich, das ist ja eigentlich auch so eine Redewendung, die man nicht mehr sagen sollte. Sagt man das eigentlich noch? Soll uns bitte der Brennerpass beantworten. Ich möchte es hiermit zurückziehen. Aber ich komme damit ja mit einer Haltung zu denen, wo die sich denken, ey, wer bist denn du, was wirst du überhaupt von mir, was? Drei Stunden spinnst du über, was wollen wir überhaupt reden? Und das meinen die überhaupt nicht böse oder müssen es nicht böse meinen.
Aber sie kennen es einfach nicht anders.
Und das habe ich jetzt durch 11 Leben noch mal deutlicher gemerkt, als ich es schon vorher gemerkt habe. Ich meine, es hat auch einen Grund, warum ich auch gewisse Leute noch gar nicht für den Rasenfunk angefragt hatte, weil ich brauche mir dann auch gar nicht eine Absage holen. Und gleichzeitig weiß ich ja auch, wenn ich mit Andi Herzog sprechen würde im Rasenfunk, selbst wenn ich bei ihm eine Stunde rausschlage, wird das ja eigentlich für den Rasenfunk nicht reichen. Und im Nachhinein wird er das verstanden haben, aber vorher werde ich es ihm nicht erklärt haben können. Und gleichzeitig ist es jetzt aber schon so, dass die Bekanntheit des Rasenfunks indirekt durch 11 Leben gestiegen ist. Meine Art und Weise, wie ich Menschen anfrage, hat sich auch ein bisschen verändert. Und das wird man auch im Rasenfunk merken. Ich will jetzt nicht jeden, den ich bei 11 Leben hatte, auch in den Rasenfunk reinziehen, weil dann wird mir das Ganze auch zu Bayern lastig, weil da jetzt halt auch logischerweise halt viele Bayern Menschen mit dabei waren. Aber definitiv der eine oder andere wird vielleicht rüber wandern. Da gab es auch schon mehr oder weniger konkrete Gespräche hin und wieder. Und ich glaube schon, dass das 11 Leben so ein bisschen, so wie es für viele Menschen anscheinend auch der Weg in ein Fußballpodcast ist, so wird es auch, glaube ich, für manche Leute der Weg in den Rasenfunk sein. Also für die Gesprächspartner, die eben jetzt dann auch gesehen haben, wie führe ich so ein Interview, wie produziere ich so was, wie denke ich über Fußball. Und da könnte es jetzt sein, dass das dann auch einen Streueffekt hat, einen Abstrahleffekt in den Rasenfunk. Eigentlich gehe ich sogar davon aus. Und dann hat sich das, auf das man verzichten musste im Rasenfunk, aufgrund von Elfleben, wo vielleicht auch nicht jeder Verständnis für hat, weil ihm per se erstmal Elfleben total egal ist und er oder sie vielleicht auch gar nicht reingehört hat. Auf das, auf das man verzichten musste, das wird hoffentlich ausgewogen durch etwas, was Elfleben dann auch indirekt mit dem Rasenfunk macht, hoffe ich. Aber es wird noch eine Weile dauern.
Ja, genau, das ist ja der Punkt, auf den ich gerade noch raus wollte. Elfleben hieß ja am Anfang auch Elffolgen. Aber daraus ist jetzt so nicht wirklich was geworden. Das habt ihr ja mittlerweile auch offiziell verkündet, dass es ein bisschen mehr wird. Auch wenn ich mich recht ins Sinne, dass es nicht so richtig klar ist, wie viel mehr.
Ja gut, ich bin ja nicht bescheuert. Also intern gibt es da natürlich Planungen. Aber ja, da hätte ich schon ganz gerne die Mimik vom einen oder anderen Rasenfunk-Hörer oder Hörerinnen gesehen, als ich das verkündet habe. Weil Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen das natürlich. Es wird, es dauert immer länger, als der Max es ankündigt. Das war nur für alle Elfleben-Hörerinnen eine neue Erfahrung. Ja, also es werden mehr als 11 Folgen. Es war ja ursprünglich mit den 11 Folgen. Das hatte ehrlich gesagt mit Elfleben, also mit dem Namen Elfleben gar nicht so viel zu tun. Leider habe ich diesen Part aus Elfleben rausgeschmissen, wo ich das Ganze erkläre, wie eigentlich die Namensgenese zustande kommt. Aber es war mir dann doch zu selbstreferenziell. Und man mag es kaum glauben, aber ich straffe ja die Folgen unglaublich. Ich versuche eigentlich zu gucken.
Aber es waren vor allem ja, es waren ja auch mal 11 Folgen mit je 45 Minuten geplant, oder?
Ja, also ja waren sie geplant. Aber da war ich mir immer schon klar, dass wir über eine Stunde landen würden bei bestimmten Folgen. Nur wenn du so etwas pitchst und dann mit einem Auftraggeber besprichst, dann wissen die auch noch nicht so genau, wie der Max arbeitet. Und dann natürlich sage ich denen dann ja immer zwischen 45 Minuten und 60 Minuten. Und jetzt Folge 9 hat fast zwei Stunden und kein einziger hat auch nur reagiert auf diese Länge. Also negativ, im positiven gab es so ja voll gut. Aber da habe ich mir auch so ein bisschen das Publikum ehrlicherweise hoffentlich erzogen, dass ich leicht verdaulicher gestartet bin und dann irgendwann auf der Komplexitätsebene gelandet bin, die ich mir wünsche für sowas. Du kannst nicht mit einer 2-Stunden-Folge starten, aber es hat mich persönlich nicht so ganz überrascht, dass es jetzt auf einmal wieder so lange Folgen geworden sind.
Ja, und wir sind ja auch am Ende in der Podcast-Welt. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, dann ist es halt so, Podcasts dauern so lange, wie ihr Inhalt dauert. Und die sollten natürlich nicht langatmig werden, aber ich glaube, das kann man jetzt keiner der 11 Leben folgen und auch den wenigsten Rasenfunk folgen nachsagen.
Genau, und die Länge soll nie Selbstzweck werden. Also das machen wir ja sonst hoffentlich auch nicht, dass wir unsere Sendung veröffentlichen und sagen, hier guck mal sechs Stunden, wie geil ist das denn? Wir haben sechs Stunden über T-Max-Y geredet, sondern wir haben über dieses Thema geredet und das hat halt dann sechs Stunden gedauert. So soll der Dreh immer sein. Und das ist der große Vorteil von Podcasts. Und gleichzeitig habe ich noch nie so viele, man sagt ja immer kill your darlings, also Stellen rausschmeißen, die haben eigentlich sehr gut gefallen. Ich habe noch nie so viele darlings umgebracht, wie bei 11 Leben. Und ich hoffe, dass man das auch merkt, wenn man 11 Leben hört. Da ist eigentlich kein Satz aus rhetorischem Grund drin, oder weil es jetzt noch eine Stieblüte ist, oder weil es jetzt einfach an der Stelle noch mal eine weitere Schleife dreht. Jeder Absatz bringt dich inhaltlich bei 11 Leben weiter. Und gerade im Max-Handlungsstrang, da habe ich viele, viele Sachen rausgeschmissen, wo dann auch Teile aus dem Team geschrien haben vor Schmerz. Und gesagt haben, nein, erzähl das doch, das ist doch lustig, das interessiert doch die Leute. Und ich dachte mir immer so, ja, vielleicht interessiert es sich vielleicht aber auch nicht. Und wenn es das ganze Ding nicht vorantreibt, komm, dann schmeiße ich es jetzt raus. Also ich habe unglaublich viel rausgestrichen und auch weggelassen. Man mag das ja nicht glauben, wie viel man dann doch bei so einem langen Projekt dann doch weglässt. Nichts ist aus Selbstzweck drin. Und letztlich ist das ja dann auch Teil dessen, warum dann, obwohl die Länge jetzt dann auch wieder bei Elf Leben so eskaliert, ähnlich wie im Rasenfunk, aber es A, vielleicht man es gar nicht so sehr merkt und es aber vor allem auch zu keinen inhaltlichen Debatten geführt hat. Also wir haben durchaus die Vertreter im Team, die dann, die sofort sagen, wenn ich, wenn ich denen das Manuskript und die erste eingelesene Version einer Folge hochlade und die sehen, die ist länger als eine Stunde, kommt sofort, oh Gott, das müssen wir ganz schlimm kürzen. Aber sogar aus dieser Ecke kamen dann irgendwann sehr, sehr viel weniger Kürzungswünsche. Also so hat sich das halt in der Welt.
Okay, Max, aber dann sag uns jetzt, wann und wo können wir für wieviel Geld den Directors Cut mit Kommentaren kaufen? Indem dann jede Folge dreieinhalb Stunden dauert.
Nee, da müsste ich ja nochmal jede Folge neu einsprechen. Und das täte zwar den frühen Folgen gut, weil da hatte ich noch nicht die großartige Silvana an meiner Seite, die mir jetzt dabei geholfen hat, dass ich mich nicht mehr anhöre wie ein Fünfklässler beim Einsprechen der Skripte. Also jetzt bin ich glaube ich ein Achtklässler. Ich glaube ich komme so langsam an meinem Leistungsoptimum an, was eben halt ohne ein professionelles Sprachtraining bei einem Coach dann nicht mehr zu leisten ist. Das wäre zwar vielleicht ganz gut, wenn ich die neu einsprechen würde, aber nee, das will man nicht. Und es waren ja auch glaube ich im Zweifel dann häufig auch die richtigen Entscheidungen. Zwei, drei Sachen habe ich rausgeschmissen, die tun mir ein bisschen leid. Und vor allem in den ersten Folgen habe ich mich nicht getraut, auch manche Dinge zu erzählen. Also während ich in der Folge 9 ganz wie selbstverständlich über Rassismus in Deutschland spreche und über die Entwicklung der DDR und der Wiedervereinigung in Anführungszeichen mit den neuen Bundesländern, habe ich mich in Folge 1 nicht getraut, darüber zu sprechen, dass ja in der Jugend von Uli Hoeneß, als er 17, 18 Jahre alt war, ja auch gleichzeitig in die Hochzeit der Hippies in den USA und dann auch in Deutschland war, gegen Pershing-Raketen demonstriert wurde. Und die Frage ja auch steht, wie ordnet sich jemand wie Paul Breitner, wie jemand wie Uli Hoeneß in diese Zeit eigentlich ein? Was unterscheidet sie dann zum Beispiel auch zur gesellschaftlichen Bedeutung und Wahrnehmung von Günter Netzer? Das habe ich mich in Folge 1 und 2 noch nicht getraut. Solche großen Fässer aufzumachen, weil ich auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl hatte, aus welcher Legitimation heraus tue ich das. Und jetzt in Folge 9 habe ich es dann doch irgendwie gemacht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, na komm, ich erzähle es jetzt halt einfach, bisher war ja das Feedback, dass es euch alle interessiert, die ihr es hört. Also deswegen wäre es vielleicht gar nicht gut, den Director's Cut zu veröffentlichen. Vielleicht ist diese Genese dann doch auch richtig. Auch wenn es, ah, zwei, drei Anekdoten sind schon lustig. Aber vielleicht mal auf einem Rasen von Hörerinnen treffen, wenn man sich wieder treffen darf.
Genau, und ich wollte gerade sagen, wir brauchen ja auch noch ein bisschen Raum dafür, dass wir dann noch mal abschließend über F-Leben sprechen, wenn ihr fertig seid. Ende nächsten Jahres oder wann wird das sein?
Im Frühling 2021. Also ich rechne damit, März wird der goldenen Monat werden.
Es wird einen Kurzpass zum Abschluss des von F-Leben geben. Die besten Geschichten, die ihr in F-Leben nicht gehört habt.
Ja, interessant. Wir könnten natürlich auch ein Q&A dazu machen.
Das war natürlich völlig unabgestimmt. Also nehmt mich besser nicht beim Wort.
Gucken wir mal. Also F-Leben, irgendwann wird es vorbei sein. Und dann schnaufe ich ein bisschen durch, so gut es geht. Und dann geht es aber im Rasenfunk Fullspeed weiter. Dann kommen auch tolle Tribünengespräche. Und im Nachhinein gehören beide Dinge ja dann doch auch irgendwie zusammen. F-Leben und Rasenfunk. Ja, im Grunde schon. Die Erkenntnis, dass ich es nicht in ein Tribünengespräch gepresst bekomme, war ja wesentlicher Teil, nachdem das Projekt schon mal beendet war, es dann doch wieder aufzugreifen. Das muss man ja auch dazu sagen. Das Tribünengespräch Uli Hoeneß hätte nie so gut und tief werden können, wie jetzt F-Leben gerade wird. Aber deswegen gab es diese Connection zwischen Rasenfunk und F-Leben, die gab es ja immer schon. Dass ich mich schon ganz lange mit der Idee schwanger getragen habe, könnte ich es nicht vielleicht auch doch in den Rasenfunk ziehen und es dann aber aus ganz bestimmten Gründen auch nicht gemacht habe.
Gut, aber jetzt waren wir ja schon ein Stück weit dabei, was im nächsten Jahr so passiert. Nämlich einerseits wird irgendwann im nächsten Jahr F-Leben beendet werden. Dann geht es natürlich auch für den Rasenfunk weiter, eben wie Max gesagt hat, dann ab irgendwann vielleicht Anfang Mitte des Jahres, dann mit erhöhtem Output in anderen Sendungen. Aber wir gucken auch aus anderen Gründen so ein bisschen in die Zukunft des Rasenfunks, Max. Da schwebt so ein bisschen das Damoklesschwert über dieser Sendung. Und ich glaube, es wäre ein guter Zeitpunkt, jetzt da mal auf dieses Thema zu sprechen zu kommen. Die große Überschrift ist Spotify.
Spotify und...
In Klammer und andere Plattformen.
Genau. Und wir brauchen eure Rückmeldung, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ja, also die Entwicklung des Rasenfunks. Für uns war Reichweite ganz lang unwichtig, weil wir es nur aus Spaß gemacht haben, den Rasenfunk. Und dann spielt es eine Rolle für einen persönlich, ob jetzt eine Sendung von 10.000 oder von 1.000 Leuten gehört wird. Aber ob es 10.000 oder 11.000 sind, ist ehrlich gesagt nicht das große Thema. Und das hat uns ja auch die große Freiheit gegeben, die eigentlich kein anderes Medium bietet und vor allem keine Redaktion sich herausnehmen kann. Dass es bei uns völlig egal ist, ob der Schwerpunkt auf dem FC Augsburg liegt oder auf dem FC Bayern. Und dass es eigentlich auch egal ist, wie catchy die Sendungsüberschrift ist. Ich kann das mit dieser Gewissheit sagen, weil ich da am Anfang der Zeit des Rasenfunks durchaus experimentiert habe und gesehen habe, also wenn es einen Effekt gibt, dann ist er halbwegs zu vernachlässigen und vor allem für uns inhaltlich nicht wichtig. Und diese Gelassenheit gegenüber den Zahlen, die hat sich natürlich wesentlich verändert. Als wir erkannt haben, der Rasenfunk in der Form, wie wir ihn machen, muss finanziell auch etwas abwerfen, weil es nicht parallel zu meinem zweiten Job lief. Und ab dann hat die Reichweite des Rasenfunks eine größere Rolle für uns gespielt, weil wir mit potenziell 1.000 neuen HörerInnen eben auch einen gewissen Prozentsatz an potenziell neuen Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen bekommen haben. Und in diese Zeit hinein ist auch die Entscheidung gefallen, dass wir den Rasenfunk auch bei Spotify anbieten, in der Sekunde, in der das dort möglich war. Also das waren die Beweggründe für uns zu sagen, trotz einiger Bedenken, über die wir jetzt dann gleich noch sprechen werden, mit Spotify wollen wir auf die Reichweite, die wir über Spotify bekommen, nicht verzichten, weil wir brauchen sie, um den Rasenfunk finanziell auf gesunde Beine zu stellen und eben dafür zu sorgen, dass ich nur noch den Rasenfunk mache. Außer F-Leben, aber gut. Wussten wir damals ja auch noch nicht, wie sich das entwickelt. Und das hat sich so ja auch bewährt, muss man sagen. Man kann das nicht voneinander trennen, da werden wir auch gleich drüber sprechen. Aber letztlich haben wir unser Ziel erreicht und da hat Spotify uns auch geholfen.
Ja, lass uns vielleicht mal ein bisschen das Ganze von Anfang an aufrollen. Was ist denn eigentlich das Problem mit Spotify? Warum ist es denn überhaupt kritisch zu sehen?
Ja, ich hoffe, dass ich es auf den Punkt bringen kann. Ich meine, wir führen ja diese Diskussionen im Grunde ja auch schon seit mehreren Jahren. Das Medium Podcast ist für mich das letzte verbliebene Medium, in dem man journalistische Inhalte produziert, das von einer unglaublichen Freiheit geprägt ist. Und zwar Freiheit für alle Beteiligten. Sowohl für die Produzentinnen, dass man eine 5-Stunden-Sendung gleichberechtigt neben einer 20-Minuten-Sendung produzieren kann. Wie wir unsere Sendung machen, liegt komplett bei uns. Und wir nutzen diese Freiheit ja auch in alle Richtungen aus. Vielleicht extremer als 99% der anderen Podcasts, weil wir eben kurze Formate haben, lange Formate, super lange Formate, Gesprächsformate usw. usf. Also diese Freiheit ist für den Rasenfunk elementar wichtig. Nur deshalb ist der Rasenfunk der Rasenfunk, weil es diese Freiheit gibt. Und diese Freiheit bezieht sich aber nicht nur auf unsere Seite, eben auf die Art und Weise, wie wir unsere Sendungen gestalten, sondern sie bezieht sich auch auf die Seite der Hörerinnen und Hörer, die in der Art und Weise, wie sie Podcasts konsumieren, eben auch eine sehr hohe Freiheit haben. Sie können wählen, über welche Plattform sie das hören wollen. Es gibt Leute, die machen es über unsere Webseite. Es gibt Leute, die machen es über YouTube. Und ganz, ganz viele machen es über Podcast-Apps, die alle unterschiedliche Funktionen zur individuellen Anpassung an das Hörerlebnis bieten. Also erhöhte Geschwindigkeit, Kapitelmarken, das Herauskürzen von Stille, das Zurück- und Vor- und Zurückspringen innerhalb einer Folge, das automatisierte Herunterladen, wenn man im WLAN ist, dass man quasi, also so nutze ich zumindest meine Podcast-App, ich hab immer meine Podcasts mit dabei, ich mach mir da gar keine Gedanken drüber, weil das macht die App für mich automatisiert. Also sprich, auch auf dieser Seite des Konsumierens von Podcasts gibt es eine Freiheit, die es verglichen mit anderen Medien, Online, Radioprint, in dieser Form nicht gibt. Und beide Freiheiten leben aber davon, unter anderem davon, dass die Plattformen, auf denen Podcasts konsumiert wird, divers sind. Dass es eben diese Auswahl an Plattformen gibt und es nicht die eine gibt, die sich als den wesentlichen Ort etabliert, an dem man Podcasts konsumiert. Es gibt eben kein YouTube für Podcasts oder kein Netflix für bestimmte Podcastproduktionen, auch wenn das viele von sich behaupten wollen. Aber es gibt es das noch nicht. Und es gibt auch nicht fest definierte Fernsehsender, in denen Podcasts laufen. Und das ermöglicht diese Freiheit nach allen Richtungen hin. Und da scheint sich jetzt aber etwas zu verändern.
Genau, und vielleicht muss man da nochmal ein bisschen kurz den technischen Aufschlag machen, ohne dazu tief einzusteigen. Die Basis für diese freie Empfangbarkeit von Podcasts sind sogenannte Feeds, RSS-Feeds. Die einen oder anderen haben es vielleicht schon gehört. Viele werden es kennen, andere vielleicht nicht. Ist auch gar nicht so wichtig. Es ist aber eben ein standardisierter Weg, Audiodateien in einer in der Regel chronologischen Reihenfolge auszuliefern. Sehr analog zu dem, wie Blogs auch schon seit vielen Jahren ausgeliefert werden, die, wenn man es jetzt mal gar nicht so unter dem Blogbegriff sammelt, sondern vielleicht eher als Website, natürlich genauso noch als freies Medium existieren. Aber genau dazu gibt es eben analog die Podcasts seit vielen Jahren. Und das, was Max eben gesagt hat mit den Plattformen, das war eben die Realität, wie Podcasts seit, ich glaube, 20 Jahren stattfinden. Also ich glaube, mit den iPods, mit den ersten kamen das Thema Podcasts auf. Und das war sehr, sehr lange, sehr, sehr klein. Es war auch ein bisschen umständlich. Mittlerweile ist das alles viel, viel einfacher geworden. Aber leider muss man auch dazu sagen, eben noch nicht einfach genug, sodass jetzt auch eine gewisse Lücke immer noch entstand, die es eben zum Beispiel Plattformen wie Spotify ermöglicht, das Thema noch mal ein bisschen zugänglicher und einfacher zu machen. Und das ist jetzt die Entwicklung, die wir in den letzten Jahren sehen. Spotify gekommen als Musik-Abo-Dienst mit der Option, das auch kostenlos zu hören mit entsprechender Werbepräsentation und dann später glaube ich auch noch inhaltlichen Einschränkungen. Aber im Grunde sind da die Podcasts vor ein paar Jahren so ein bisschen von der Seite reingerutscht. Erst sehr stiefmütterlich. Mittlerweile ist das Thema auch für die als Plattform immer wichtiger geworden. Und mittlerweile sind Podcasts dort relativ präsent. Obwohl Funktional, das was Max eben erwähnt, hat die ganzen Features, die ein guter Podcatcher so bietet. Soweit ich das jetzt weiß. Ich nutze Spotify selber nicht mehr. Aber weitestgehend komplett dort fehlen.
Ja und man muss dazu vielleicht noch einschränkend sagen, es gab es schon früher auch im Podcastbereich, dass eine Plattform dominiert hat. Nämlich das iTunes-Verzeichnis für Podcasts ist bis heute eigentlich die wichtigste Grundlage für die Auslieferung von Podcast-Feeds gewesen. Also es gab schon immer Abhängigkeiten zu Plattformen. Was sich allerdings mit Spotify dramatisch ändert, ist zum einen der Anspruch, den die Plattformen auf die Podcasts haben und die Monetarisierung desselbigen. Also Spotify besteht oder geht kurz dazwischen.
Nie für die Auslieferung der Feeds. Es gab zwar die Möglichkeit, das über iTunes quasi zu leiten sozusagen. Und man konnte das dann in iTunes abonnieren. Aber die Feeds an sich waren davon eigentlich immer unabhängig. Apple hat nie die Feeds zur Verfügung gestellt.
Apple war die Bibliothek quasi.
Man konnte es durchschleusen quasi. Später gab es dann die Statistiken dort. Und die haben dann so ein bisschen daran festgemacht, wer wird wie viel gehört und so.
Genau, aber das war quasi der Ort, um Podcasts zu finden.
Genau.
Und dazu entwickelt sich jetzt gerade Spotify. Und das ist aus verschiedenen Gründen hat es für uns als Podcast-Produzenten eine andere Qualität, als die bisherige Situation war. Und da hängt wesentlich zusammen, was du gerade schon angeklingen hast lassen. Spotify hat zwei Produkte. Also sie kommen über Audio-Inhalte, die Video-Experimente lassen wir jetzt mal kurz außen vor. Und während man sich im Musikbereich mit den Labels irgendwann auf Verträge geeinigt hat, bei denen übrigens die einzelnen KünstlerInnen nicht sehr gut bei wegkommen, da Spotify nicht als der große Heroe der MusikerInnen aufgetreten, wobei das auch sehr mit den Labels auch zu tun hat. Das ist der eine Inhalt, den Spotify hat und für den Spotify ja auch zahlen muss. Und dann gibt es einen zweiten Audio-Inhalt, den Spotify für sich entdeckt hat. Und das sind Podcasts, bei denen die Welt ganz anders aussieht, bei denen du den Inhalt erstmal kostenlos bekommst. Spotify hat auch von uns hunderte Stunden Inhalt bekommen, ohne dafür irgendetwas zu zahlen. Das Einzige, was die PodcasterInnen zurückbekommen von Spotify, ist eben eine gewisse Reichweite, was aber ein zweischneidiges Schwert sein kann.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, das ist tatsächlich der Hebel. Der Deal ist quasi eigentlich erstmal, du bekommst meinen Inhalt, wobei das glaube ich die wenigsten so sehen. Aber was man eben von Spotify bekommt, ist eine gewisse Reichweite. Das heißt, man geht zu Spotify, weil man weiß, man erreicht dort eine gewisse Menge an Menschen. Das ist eigentlich der grundlegende Hebel, um überhaupt als Podcaster dorthin zu gehen.
Genau, das ist ja auch per se erstmal nicht schlecht, man möchte ja sein Publikum finden. Was sich jetzt allerdings bei Spotify verändert hat, sind zwei Dinge. Zum einen ist es die Relevanz, die Spotify im Markt bekommen hat, wo wir eben sehen, die nimmt immer weiter zu. Also inzwischen ist es auch so, dass Spotify sogar im Rasenfunk die Plattform ist, über die uns statistisch gesehen die meisten Menschen im Monat hören.
Nee, nicht ganz richtig, Max, stopp. Da muss ich auch, das ist zufällig, ich konnte da vorhin, als ich auf die Statistik geguckt habe, nur damit wir hier nichts Falsches sagen. Nach dem, was ich jetzt sehe, ist es die zweitgrößte Plattform, weil aus irgendeinem Grund wird Podcasts auf IOS und Podcasts auf iPhone getrennt. Das wird getrennt, gezählt in zwei Dingern. Die sind zusammen ein bisschen mehr als Spotify. Aber Spotify ist ein sehr, sehr großer Anteil. Daran führt kein Weg vorbei. Es ist fast ein Viertel der Gesamtabrufzahlen über Spotify.
Genau, das stimmt. Danke für die Einordnung. Du hast recht, das vergess ich jedes Mal wieder, dass das hier getrennt aufgewiesen wird. Aber das Wichtige zu wissen ist, die Tendenz ist steigend. Also Spotify entwickelt sich auch im Rasenfunk und generell im Podcastbereich zu einer wichtiger Plattform ist es jetzt schon. Und sie möchte die wichtigste Plattform werden. Und warum ist das jetzt für uns wichtig? Weil Spotify eine Agenda verfolgt im Podcastbereich. Spotify hat im letzten Jahr schon und dieses Jahr auch unheimlich viel Geld in Podcasts und die Infrastruktur von Podcasts investiert. Und da sprechen wir um hunderte Millionen von Dollar, die man ausgegeben hat, zum Teil um PodcasterInnen exklusiv zu Spotify zu holen, zum Teil um eigene Produktionen dort zu starten, zum Teil auch um Infrastruktur, mit der man Podcasts erstellen kann, zu kaufen, Vermarktungen zu implementieren. Das ist ein Betrag jenseits der 500 Millionen US-Dollar, der in den letzten 24 Monaten von Spotify investiert wurde. Und da muss man ja kein Albert Einstein der Ökonomie sein, um zu wissen. Das möchte sich Spotify natürlich wieder zurückholen. Spotify macht das nicht als edler Ritter der Podcastwelt, sondern das Ziel ist natürlich, mit diesen Inhalten, die die NutzerInnen in der App Spotify halten und auch die Verbindung zu dieser App steigern, das will monetarisiert werden und das wird monetarisiert werden. Und das kann man jetzt schon sehen. Und man muss aber nicht Schwarzmaler sein, um zu sehen, das wird noch zunehmen. Und ab dann wird es natürlich für ein Produkt wie unseres, das sich Werbe-, Paywall- und Sponsorenfreiheit rühmt, das ein ganz eigenes Finanzierungsmodell hat und vor allem ehrlich gesagt auch eine relativ klare Haltung zu vielen Entwicklungen da draußen im Internet. Ab dann wird es für jemanden wie uns schwierig.
Genau, man muss natürlich auch grundsätzlich sagen, das läuft natürlich ganz klar in Richtung Monopolbildung. Da sind wir auch im Grunde, wo wir jetzt für den Videobereich sagen können, dass wir da mit YouTube schon lange sind, kann man bei Spotify relativ deutlich sagen, darauf läuft es raus. Ob das jetzt nun schon genau so ist oder nicht, kann man mal dahingestellt lassen. Für mich persönlich, als einer, der jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel Musik konsumiert, aber grundsätzlich auch über eine Weile lang die freie Auswahl und die Zugänglichkeit bei Spotify geschätzt hat, ich bin jetzt seit einer Weile bei einem anderen Anbieter, konkret bei Apple Music in dem Fall, wobei das, finde ich, gar keine riesengroße Rolle spielt, weil erstmal war es einige andere und dazu zählt für mich auch Apple Music jetzt von Spotify unterscheidet, dass ich dort einen ganz klaren monatlichen Betrag bezahlt. Das gibt es auch gar nicht kostenlos, da gibt es überhaupt keine Werbung, das gehört gar nicht zum Konzept. Ich bezahle einen monatlichen Betrag ganz klar für die Musik und Punkt. Es gibt keine Vermischungen, es gibt keinen wir binden Inhalteanbieter an die Plattform, irgendwas in dieser Art und das ist für mich eigentlich so die Basis für einen fairen Deal, wo ich denke, das kann auch langfristig funktionieren. Es wird vielleicht wahrscheinlich auch bei anderen Anbietern so sein, insofern will ich da jetzt Apple Music gar nicht so rausstellen, aber das ist halt eben für mich das alternative Produkt. Die Alternativen gibt es im Moment, aber wenn es natürlich ein Anbieter schafft, den Großteil der Konsumentenschaft auf sich zu fokussieren, man sieht das im Videobereich, es gibt weiterhin Vimeo, aber die spielen in der Reichweite als Plattform quasi keine Rolle. Das heißt, wenn ich heute sage, ich starte jetzt irgendwie einen Videokanal, habe ich eigentlich keine Alternative, als den bei YouTube zu starten, es sei denn mir ist es völlig egal, ob ich über die Plattform Zuschauer erreiche oder nicht. Und das ist eben so eine Gefahr, wo wir bei Spotify hinlaufen.
Genau, mit der Anschlussfrage, ja, aber was ist denn daran schlimm? Das muss ja noch gar nicht jedem da draußen schon klar sein. Und das ist erstmal eine subjektive Antwort, die man darauf geben kann. Das muss nicht schlimm sein. De facto ist es aber so, wenn es ein Monopol gibt, egal in welchem Lebensbereich, dann kann der Monopolist die Spielregeln, nach denen Inhalte distribuiert, produziert und auch konsumiert werden, die kann er oder sie bestimmen. Und da wird es für uns sehr, sehr, sehr relevant, ob es ein Monopol im Podcastbereich gibt, im Konsum von Podcasts, gibt ja oder nein. Also als Beispiel, um mal kurz über die inhaltliche Ebene einzusteigen in das Thema, wie sehen die erfolgreichsten YouTube-Videos aus? Also wenn ich ein YouTuber oder eine YouTuberin werden möchte, dann gibt es ein bestimmtes Set an Regeln, das ich befolgen muss, damit der Algorithmus mir Reichweite verschafft und auch, weil die Konsuminteressen der breiten Masse denen zu entsprechen scheinen. Also sprich, ein optimales YouTube-Video ist zwischen 10 und 15 Minuten lang. Das Thumbnail muss bestimmte Regeln erfüllen. Die Texte müssen bestimmte Regeln erfüllen. Es gibt da ein Set an verschiedenen Regeln, die dir dabei helfen, Reichweite zu bekommen, basierend darauf, was A, YouTube analysiert hat aus seinen Nutzer-Innendaten, wie die breite Masse an Menschen YouTube-Videos konsumiert und B, wie aber auch YouTube es haben möchte. Also es könnte durchaus sein, dass die breite Masse auch 30 Minuten lange Videos konsumieren würde, aber YouTube hat natürlich ein Interesse daran, dass mehr Inhalte konsumiert werden, zwischen denen ja auch Werbung und so weiter geschaltet werden kann, dass die Zahlen für alle steigen. Also ist dann die Tendenz schon zu kürzeren Formaten da. Etwas ganz Ähnliches, es würde mich wirklich wundern, käme auch im Podcast-Bereich, wenn wir einen Monopolisten in diesem Fall, und wir sprechen dann in dem Fall nur von Spotify als möglichen Podcast-Monopol hätten. Und das wiederum macht natürlich etwas mit dem Rasenfunk. Denn wir machen drei Stunden Sendung. Wir werden weiter drei Stunden Sendung machen. Es kann aber sein, dass wir dann einfach nicht mehr zu finden sind bei Spotify oder sehr, sehr viel schlechter zu finden sind. Denn Spotify möchte das nicht, dass ihr nur drei Stunden in Rasenfunk hört. Spotify möchte, dass ihr an der Stelle dieser drei Stunden Sendung zehn Sendungen hört, die 20 Minuten lang sind, weil dann die Nutzungszahlen steigen, weil man dazwischen Werbung schalten kann, weil dann vielleicht da auch ein Spotify Original dabei ist, also eine eigene Produktion von Spotify. Das sind, glaube ich, keine Verschwörungsmythen, die hier in die Welt setzen, wenn ich dieses Szenario an die Wand male.
Na und es ist ja auch, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, aus Sicht von Spotify ist das ja alles auch völlig legitim. Das ist ein Business, die machen ihr Geschäft, die packen natürlich das im Algorithmus nach vorne, von dem sie denken, das kommt am besten an. Weil man kennt das auch von YouTube zum Beispiel mit dieser Spalte da rechts neben oder unter den Videos hier nach Einstellungen, wo die nächsten Videos vorgeschlagen werden. Man hangelt sich oft daran weiter. Das heißt, je besser diese Vorschläge sind, umso besser hält mich YouTube auf der Plattform. Du hast eben ganz nebenbei die Spotify Originals erwähnt. Das ist nochmal ein ganz großer Unterschied auch zu YouTube, die zwar auch ein bisschen selber Videos produzieren und auch schon Versuche gegangen sind, damit irgendwie andere zu bezahlen unter ihrem Label. Aber die halten das relativ klein. Und ich glaube, da gab es auch schon ein bisschen Gegenwind. Bei Spotify kräht im Moment noch kein Hahn danach, dass die sich exklusiv Podcasts einkaufen, die dann nur noch auf Spotify laufen oder eigene produzieren, die nur auf Spotify laufen. Die sind aus der restlichen Podcast-Welt komplett raus. Bestes Beispiel, ich hab vorhin kurz meine Frau erwähnt, die ist noch nicht so dick in dem Podcast-Thema drin, obwohl ich seit vielen Jahren Podcasts höre, aber sie ist jetzt auch ein bisschen drauf gekommen, hat irgendwann auch einen Podcast entdeckt, den es auch bei Spotify gab. Sie fand es dann ein bisschen einfacher, hat da weitergehört. Die sind jetzt seit Sommer bei Spotify unter Vertrag und sind jetzt raus aus anderen Podcasts. Meine Frau ist jetzt gerade weg von Spotify, weil sie es eigentlich aus verschiedenen Gründen auch nicht gut fand und kann jetzt den Podcast nicht mehr hören. Und allein die Tatsache, dass sie so ein bisschen dann anz überlegen kam, ob es dann immer noch sinnvoll ist, auf Spotify wegzugehen, zeigt schon, was das Problem daran ist.
Genau, und gleichzeitig ist ja, wenn die, ich fange sehr oft an mit genau an dich anzuschließen, das tut mir leid, aber du sagst halt nur richtige Sachen. Daran liegt das. Also der große Unterschied ist, wenn die Plattform auch selbst Inhalte in nennenswerter Form und Relevanz anbietet, dann gibt das dann natürlich auch ein Ungleichgewicht. Denn wenn ich nicht nur Schiedsrichter bin und die Regeln mache, sondern auch Mitspieler, dann muss ich jetzt auch hier wiederum nicht arg spekulieren, um mir vorstellen zu können, welche Produkte werden wie angezeigt auf Spotify. Und einfach nur das Gedankensbeispiel. Aktuell gibt es noch keinen Spotify-Fußball-Podcast. Es wird irgendwann ein Spotify-Fußball-Podcast geben. Wahrscheinlich irgendein Prominenter, der sich mit jemandem hinsetzt und völlig belanglose Gespräche über Fußball führt, so wie aktuell die Podcast-Konzepte noch bei den meisten Anbieterinnen aussehen, auch bei Spotify. Aber dann könnt ihr euch ja einfach überlegen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr dann nach Fußball-Bundesliga oder nach Fußball sucht im Podcastbereich, an welcher Stelle wird der Rasenfunk auftauchen? Wahrscheinlich nicht mehr auf eins. Und das kann man ja auch verstehen, würde ich als Spotify ja auch genauso machen. Aber sprich, damit ist absehbar, dass freie, unabhängige Produktionen, die werden vermehrt zurückgedrängt werden. Die werden irgendwann nicht mehr auffindbar. Und damit wird auch der Mehrwert, den Spotify auch aktuell auch dem Rasenfunk noch bietet, nämlich die Reichweite, der wird zurückgehen. Das ist vorhersehbar und das ist auch erklärtes Ziel von Spotify. Die gehen da eigentlich auch relativ offen mit um. Also ich hab jetzt auch schon mehrfach mit Spotify schon zu tun gehabt. Und in allen Gesprächen, die ich da hatte, da ging es auch darum, warum bietet ihr nicht zum Beispiel diesen Podcast zu jenem Thema? Das ist doch hochrelevant. Warum bietet ihr den nicht auch noch zusätzlich frei an? Ja, haben wir ausprobiert, hat uns nichts gebracht. Und das stimmt wahrscheinlich auch wirklich. Es hat wahrscheinlich Spotify wirklich nichts gebracht, weil die verdienen kein Geld damit, wenn jemand Spotify als Produzenten von guten Podcasts wahrnimmt. Die verdienen nur Geld damit, wenn die die Nutzer in ihrer App drin halten oder in ihrem Angebot drin halten. Und denen sind so freie Projekte wie wir, die sind ihnen ehrlich gesagt völlig egal und können ihnen auch egal sein. Ich kann das auch nachvollziehen. Und das ist aber für uns in dem Moment ein Problem, wo Spotify die Marktmacht bekommt, die es jetzt gerade schon hat.
Genau, jetzt müssen wir aber auch mal die Gegenseite beleuchten. Nämlich, du hast es eben schon erwähnt, die Vorteile, die Spotify noch hat, nämlich eben die Reichweite für uns. Ich finde, das muss man auch noch mal ein bisschen klarer sagen, wenn jetzt der eine oder andere Hörer wird denken, ja was macht ihr denn da überhaupt noch? Warum seid ihr da überhaupt und warum seid ihr nicht lang schon wieder weg? Da muss man einmal sagen, warum sind wir da überhaupt? Wir haben das damals schon kontrovers diskutiert, weil wir eine ähnliche Entwicklung damals schon befürchtet haben. Wir sind da schlicht, weil wir zu einer Zeit dazukommen konnten, zu der es beim Rasenfunk durchaus ein bisschen auf der Kippe stand, ob das alles klappt mit der Finanzierung, mit der Reichweite. Und wir wussten, okay, bei Spotify damals war die Reichweite noch nicht so riesig, aber wir wussten, da ist ein gewisses Potenzial. Das können wir in unserer Situation nicht auslassen, wenn wir alles dafür tun wollen, um mit unserem Konzept zu überleben. Und das klingt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen dramatisch, weil natürlich hätten wir auch andere Wege gehen können, um die Finanzierung zu sichern, die wir aber alle nicht wollten. Insofern war das dann der Weg, der für uns der zugehende war. Und wie wir vorhin gesagt haben, wir haben jetzt fast ein Viertel der Hörer, hören uns über Spotify. Wie viele uns jetzt darüber gefunden haben, darüber reden wir noch gleich. Aber das ist für uns jetzt einfach eine Basis, die ganz schwer einfach wegzuwerfen ist. Und da kommt eben ein Aspekt dazu, zu der Anzahl der Hörer, die uns da hören, kommt auch die Frage, wie viel, und da kann man jetzt, wenn man über Spotify was Positives sagen möchte, sicherlich auch sagen, da hat Spotify ein Stück weit auch was für die Branche getan, nämlich sie bringen das Thema Podcasts Menschen näher, die anderweitig vielleicht nicht drüber gestolpert werden. Eben weil es mit auf dieser Musikplattform ist, weil es vielleicht eingebunden in so einen Daily-Mix ist oder einfach irgendwo prominent präsentiert wird und nur ein Klick weg ist. Ansonsten ist es halt doch die Podcast-App, die man vielleicht installieren muss, vielleicht ist sie schon installiert, aber man muss sie extra öffnen, man muss sie lernen, sie zu bedienen. Und bei Spotify ist es halt einfach sehr leicht, Podcasts zu hören. Und das ist natürlich eben neben der Zahl derer, die uns hören bei Spotify, jetzt auch so eine Überlegung, wo wir sagen, okay, wie viele finden uns eigentlich über Spotify? Wie viele kommen erst auf den Rasenfunk, weil sie uns bei Spotify zufällig gefunden haben?
Ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und um einmal kurz noch bei dem einzusteigen, womit du begonnen hast, du hast gesagt, du möchtest es nicht so dramatisch darstellen, de facto war, also in der Phase, in der wir entschieden haben, dann doch mit allen Bauchschmerzen, die wir damals schon hatten, zu Spotify zu gehen, war das schon eine dramatische Entscheidung für uns. Weil im Grunde damals für uns klar war, wenn wir jetzt nicht innerhalb von sechs Monaten auf eine gewisse Spendensumme kommen, die wir brauchen, einfach, dass ich meinen anderen Job auslaufen lassen kann, meine Selbstständigkeit auf den Rasenfunk konzentrieren kann, dann hätte das Auswirkungen auf den Rasenfunk gehabt. Also dann hätte es vielleicht keine Schlusskonferenz mehr gegeben und nur noch Tribünengespräche. Es hätte vielleicht auch keine Tribünengespräche gegeben und nur noch alle zwei Wochen eine Schlusskonferenz. So wäre es nicht mehr weitergegangen. Und das war uns beiden ja schon klar. Deswegen haben wir ja auch diesen Schritt genommen. Und deswegen war das aber schon, da steckte schon eine hohe Fallhöhe für uns drin. Sonst wären wir auch nicht zu Spotify gegangen. Und wir wurden dann auch quasi für dieses Risiko belohnt. Da kam noch mit dazu, dass wir auch den Fußballkulturpreis als Podcast des Jahres mit einem Honorar gewonnen haben. Der hat uns da auch nochmal einen Monat über die Runden geholfen. Aber es war damals schon eine heikle Phase im Rasenfunk, wo das, was wir geboten haben, mit dem, was wir dafür gekriegt haben, noch nicht so übereinging, dass es weiter so hätte weiterlaufen können. Also 2019 wäre für uns ansonsten war quasi klar, entweder wird das das Jahr, in dem wir den Rasenfunk auf finanzielle Beine stellen, so, dass wir dieses Programm weiter durchziehen können, wie es jetzt ist, oder der Rasenfunk hätte sich in seinem Charakter wesentlich verändert. Das hätte uns beiden unglaublich wehgetan. Und wer weiß, ob ich es wirklich durchgezogen hätte. Ich hänge ja dann doch so sehr an allen Sendungen. Aber im Grunde war das die Ausgangslage. Und so kamen wir zu Spotify. Und jetzt haben wir dann aber damit das Problem, was du dann ja letztlich beschrieben hast. Für uns ist ja jeder Hörer und jede Hörerin ein guter Hörer. Wir wollen gehört werden und wir freuen uns. Und jede Supporterin und jeder Supporter ist für uns die Grundlage für all das, was wir hier gerade machen. Ohne euch da draußen geht es nicht. Das müsst ihr euch klar machen. Es sind tausend Schultern, die uns tragen, die unsere Gäste tragen, die den Rasenfunk tragen. Wenn diese tausend Schultern weg sind, dann ist der Rasenfunk-Ding gibt es dann einfach nicht. Dann funktioniert all das, was wir tun, nicht. Und es gibt natürlich auch keinen guten und keinen schlechten Rasenfunk-Supporter und uns-Supporterin. Also jemand, der uns über Spotify hört, hat natürlich für uns die selbe Bedeutung wie jemand, der uns über eine andere Plattform hört. Und es gibt sicherlich auch Leute da draußen, die uns über Spotify konsumieren und gleichzeitig Supporter und Supporterinnen sind, die ja dann auch, finde ich, aus diesem aus diesem Fakt heraus einen gewissen Anspruch ableiten können, dass sie sagen können, naja, also ich unterstütze euch schon finanziell, eigentlich möchte ich euch jetzt auch gerne hier hören, wo es mir am liebsten ist. Das Problem ist, dass wir nicht wissen, welche Zahlen dahinter liegen. Wir können sehen, wie viele Leute hören uns über Spotify und über andere Plattformen. Wir können das allerdings noch nicht verknüpfen mit der Information, wie viele davon unterstützen uns auch, in welcher Art und Weise und wie sehr ist eigentlich dieses Problembewusstsein für die Monopolstellung von Spotify oder die baldige Monopolstellung von Spotify schon bei euch da draußen angekommen? Und deshalb haben wir uns etwas überlegt.
Wir haben für mich zum ersten Mal in dieser Form, für Max vielleicht nicht, aber man hat gemerkt, wir haben es beide noch nicht so oft gemacht. Wir haben ein bisschen zusammen an einem Umfrageformular gebastelt und haben etwas daraus bekommen, was wir denken, was uns ein bisschen Aufschluss geben kann, ein bisschen Einblick in diese Welt zu bekommen, die Max eben beschrieben hat, nämlich in die Frage, hört ihr uns bei Spotify? Warum eigentlich? Was erinnert euch daran, uns woanders zu hören? Unterstützt er uns finanziell? Macht ihr es davon abhängig, ob wir bei Spotify sind oder nicht? Auch wenn er uns bei Spotify nicht hört, wir würden uns super, super freuen und es würde uns wirklich helfen, wenn ihr dieses Formular für uns ausfüllt und uns ein bisschen Infos an die Hand gebt. Es ist natürlich alles völlig anonym. Ihr müsst keine E-Mail-Adresse hinterlassen, nichts dergleichen. Es geht uns wirklich nur darum, ein bisschen Einblick zu bekommen und ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür, was würde denn passieren, wenn wir uns in absehbarer Zeit entschließen und sagen, ok, wenn wir jetzt diese Dinge so sehen, wie wir sie jetzt geschildert haben, ist dann nicht die einzige Konsequenz, irgendwann bei Spotify rauszugehen. Aber was passiert dann mit uns? Verlieren wir dann die Hälfte unserer Supporter? Können wir vielleicht mit ein bisschen Überzeugungs- und Aufklärungsarbeit dazu beitragen, dass ihr uns auch überall anders, was natürlich ganz nebenbei erwähnt, ihr könnt euch das wahrscheinlich denken, aber das können wir jetzt schon garantieren, daran wird sich nichts ändern, dass ihr uns überall anders hören könnt, wo es nur irgendwie geht und unbedenklich ist. Also die freien Kanäle werden immer offen bleiben. Aber da wollen wir eben jetzt so ein bisschen Einblick bekommen, inwieweit das uns beeinflussen würde, wenn wir sagen würden, zumindest von Supporter-Seite, wenn wir sagen würden, Spotify, das können wir eigentlich nicht länger unterstützen.
Deshalb gibt es die Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen-Umfrage. Ihr findet den Link natürlich in den Show Notes. Ihr wisst es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und die richtet sich auch ausdrücklich nicht nur an diejenigen, die uns über Spotify hören. Also die allererste Frage ist, wie hörst du den Rasenfunk? Und wir freuen uns, wenn einfach jeder der von euch die, was meinst du, drei Minuten Zeit, maximal fünf Minuten Zeit, ich glaube mehr, nee, so viel ist es wahrscheinlich nicht. Genau, also wir verkaufen euch da keine Waschmaschine und wir wollen auch nicht euer Bruttonetto-Einkommen, euer Bruttonetter, euer Bruttohauser als Einkommen wissen und so was so bei solchen Marketing-Umfragen mit drinsteckt. Nein, es ist wirklich kurz gehalten, aber wir haben da schon die für uns wesentlichen Dinge, fragen wir da ab. Jeder von euch, wir würden uns freuen, wenn jeder und jeder von euch diese Umfrage kurz beantwortet mit einem ehrlichen Feedback. Wir können auch damit leben, wenn ihr sagt, ey, diese ganze Debatte ist völlig albern, es interessiert mich null. Ich möchte euch einfach nur so hören, wie ich das gerne hätte. Und dann ist das vielleicht über Spotify. Bitte seid so aufrichtig, wie wir immer versuchen, euch gegenüber zu sein. Und macht bitte bei dieser Umfrage mit, damit wir ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, worüber reden wir hier eigentlich. Weil es ist vielleicht schon klar geworden, aus dem, wie wir jetzt gesprochen haben über Spotify, zur Haltung des Rasenfunk und zu unseren Werten passt ganz viel, was sich bei Spotify gerade entwickelt, nicht. Und trotzdem haben wir ja alle ein Interesse, dass es den Rasenfunk gibt in dieser Form. Und wir können, wir wollen aber auch nicht den Rasenfunk gefährden, aus ganz eigennutzigen Motiven heraus. Das heißt, wir brauchen ein besseres Gefühl dafür. Worüber reden wir hier eigentlich? Wie viele von euch hören uns dort? Wie viele supporten uns dort? Wie seid ihr vielleicht auch auf uns aufmerksam geworden? Und sollten wir von Spotify weggehen, dann wissen wir ja, dass wir auf viele Dinge verzichten. Und dann können wir auf die bewusst verzichten. Nur die Frage des Supports und wie viele von euch davon betroffen sind, das können wir gerade nur so vage abschätzen. Und wir, ihr habt es ja vielleicht schon gemerkt, wir denken immer sehr lange nach, bevor wir Entscheidungen treffen. Und dafür brauchen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr Futter.
Und man muss vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen, also einerseits, Josh ist eben noch erwähnt, wie viele von euch betroffen sind. Also gar nicht nur, was den Support angeht, sondern wir wollen natürlich auch, dass ihr, die uns jetzt über Spotify hört und die vielleicht gar nicht wissen, wie das sonst funktioniert. Da gibt es bestimmt ganz viele und das ist auch völlig okay. Wir wollen auch drahtsicher gehen, dass wir alles, was in unserer Hand liegt, dafür tun, um euch weiter zu ermöglichen, uns zu hören. Sollten wir irgendwann mal weggehen. Und dann muss man auch dazu sagen, es gibt jetzt eigentlich keinen Grund, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt alles abzublasen und uns schreiend davon zu laufen. Aber wir wollen halt auch gerüstet sein für spätestens den Zeitpunkt, wenn es denn dann...
Selbst wenn wir daran beteiligt werden würden, was ich nicht vermute. Was nicht passieren wird.
Genau, und dann wollen wir lieber vorbereitet sein, ein bisschen Bescheid wissen, bis dahin vielleicht auch ein bisschen Aufklärungsarbeit leisten, um euch vielleicht auch erst mal zu zeigen, wie viel besser es auch sein kann, den Rasenfunk anders zu hören, wie viele tolle Features es da gibt und wie viele tausende andere Podcasts, die allermeisten nämlich, die auch auf anderen Plattformen und Apps hörbar sind. Und genau, da wollen wir eben jetzt unseres dafür tun. Und das wäre schön, wenn ihr euren Beitrag dazu leistet, indem ihr unsere Umfrage ausfüllt und uns da ein bisschen Einblick gebt. Das wäre super klasse.
Frank, ich habe gerade im Sinne des Brennerpasses Fake-Hörer-Post bekommen von Franz Josef West aus Zutzenhausen. Was wäre denn für euch die liebste Art und Weise, wie ich meinen geliebten Rasenfunk hören kann? Franz Josef West? Kennst du denn unsere geschätzten Hörerinnen? Im Grunde ist aktuell die Antwort, auch wenn sich das vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen komisch anhört, jeder andere Weg als Spotify ist erstmal besser, weil wir eben einfach dieses Monopol nicht haben wollen. Vielleicht können wir zwei an der Stelle einfach mal sagen, wie wir Podcasts konsumieren. Wir sind ja tatsächlich Experten in dem Bereich. Das trau ich mir jetzt wirklich mal zu sagen. Weiß ich seit wie vielen Jahren du schon Podcasts hörst. Also ich nutze auf Android die App Pocketcasts und die ist nicht perfekt, aber sie erfüllt sehr viele Dinge sehr gut. Weil sie hat die wichtigen Funktionen, die ich gerne haben möchte. Erhöhte Geschwindigkeit, automatisches Herauschneiden von Stille. Kapitelmarken sind für mich ganz wichtig. Ich finde auch die meisten Podcasts darüber sehr schnell. Automatisierte Download, wenn ich im WLAN bin. Automatisierte Playlist-Erstellung. Das sind alles eigentlich die Sachen, die ich gerne von einer Podcast-Ed haben möchte. Und bei allen, es gibt noch ein paar kleinere Dinge, die mir persönlich am Pocketcasts nicht gefallen. Aber insgesamt bin ich mit dieser App. Also ich habe jetzt gerade geguckt, ich nutze sie seit 2015. Habe 120 Tage und vier Stunden Podcasts über diese App konsumiert. Also, dann muss ich sie eigentlich auch empfehlen. Pocketcasts nutze ich und die kann man auch für iOS verwenden.
Genau, da kann ich auch gleich daran anschließen, das erstmal um deine Frage zu beantworten. Ich bin ziemlich sicher, seit 2008 höre ich Podcasts, also zwölf Jahre. Ich nutze Pocketcasts auch auf iOS und kann es auch sehr empfehlen mittlerweile. Es ist eine richtig gute App geworden. Ich finde gar nicht so viel störende Punkte daran. Übrigens interessanter Side-Fact. Pocketcasts war und ist, glaube ich, von einem australischen Entwickler. Die wurden vor, ich glaube, zwei Jahren ungefähr von NPR übernommen, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. NPR, National Public Radio, ist so ein bisschen sowas, nicht ansatzweise vergleichbar, aber ähnliches wie wieder öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk in Deutschland. Also ein bisschen öffentlich finanziert. Und genau kann ich es ehrlich gesagt, genau kann ich es nicht sagen, aber die haben quasi die Zeichen der Zeit erkannt und haben da in die App investiert. Und die hat sich seitdem auch wirklich ordentlich weiterentwickelt. Und es glaube ich mittlerweile, kann man fast sagen, die Go-To-App unabhängig von der Plattform, weil die gibt es sowohl für Android als auch für iOS, aber auch Desktop-Apps für den Mac und für Windows. Das macht es für mich ganz stark. Es gibt auch eine iPad-App und ich bin nämlich jemand, ich höre ab und an schon mal, wenn ich am Abend in Ruhe mal Zeit habe, um ein kleines Spielchen zu machen, dann lege ich mir gerne am Rechner auf den Headset einen Podcast. Und das funktioniert viel besser, wenn die Windows-App dazu da ist. Oder auch mal beim Arbeiten am Mac. Und alle Apps synchronisieren untereinander den aktuellen Stand, was man zuletzt gehört hat und wo man im letzten Podcast war. Also es ist eine wirklich feine Sache. Es gibt aber wirklich auch eine unzählige Menge guter Apps auf iOS. Alternativen jede Menge. Die eine macht das ein bisschen besser, die andere das. Da gibt es sehr, sehr viel. Google hat mittlerweile eine Podcast-App, da kann ich zum aktuellen Stand gar nicht so viel sagen. Die war am Anfang sehr basic. Ich glaube, die hat sich auch ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Alles ist im Grunde besser als Spotify. Kann man fast sagen. Man kann gar nicht sagen Spotify um Co, weil Spotify sticht da schon sehr heraus.
Genau. Und ihr bekommt vor allem Funktionen mit dazu. Also das muss man noch mit dazu sagen. Bei allem, was Spotify auch gut macht, hinsichtlich der Auffindbarkeit vom Podcast, der Einfachheit zu abonnieren, ist Spotify noch weit davon entfernt, eine Podcast-App zu sein. Also zum Beispiel die ganz, ganz wichtigen Kapitelmarken. Die fehlen einfach. Und wenn die euch in eurer App fehlen, dann...
Für jemanden, der die noch gar nicht kennt.
Ich verwende ja viel Zeit darauf, Kapitel zu erstellen. Nicht nur für die Tribüngengespräche, sondern auch für die Schlusskonferenzen. Das heißt, jedes einzelne besprochene Spiel hat ein Kapitel. Und wenn mich dieses eine Spiel, aus welchem Grund auch immer, nicht interessiert, dann ist es für mich ein Klick und ich bin automatisch beim nächsten Spiel. Oder wenn mich nur dieses Spiel interessiert, das verachte ich natürlich als Produzent dieser dreistündigen Sendung, schämt euch ihr da draußen. Aber meinetwegen, dann könnt ihr über Kapitelmarken da auch schnell hinspringen und müsst euch das nicht zusammensuchen. Der Theorien stecken da auch noch viele andere Dinge mit drin, die man mit Kapitelmarken machen kann. Aber allein diese bessere Struktur einer Sendung, die hat schon viele Vorteile. Und es gibt immer mal wieder kleinere Probleme bei einzelnen Apps mit Kapitelmarken. Also wenn es von euch da draußen Pocketcast-Hörer oder Antennapod-Hörer oder Overcast oder Castro-Hörer und so weiter gibt, bei denen die Kapitelmarken nicht angezeigt werden. Jede Schlusskonferenz, jedes Tribüngespräch und manche Kurzpass... Also dieser Kurzpass hier, der sollte auch Kapitelmarken haben. Wenn ihr die nicht habt, dann abonniert mal den entsprechenden Feed neu oder zieht euch den mp3-Feed von unserer Seite. Das haben wir da auch, wie ich mich richtig erinnere, alles mal beschrieben. Das ist zum Beispiel eine ganz wichtige Funktion für Podcasts, wie ich finde, auch um sich innerhalb von so langen Produktionen, wie wir sie haben, zurechtzufinden. Das ist ja oft gar nicht so einfach.
Ja, und manchmal ist es einfach auch so, also mir geht es selber so beim Hören vom Podcast, es ist vielleicht nicht immer, dass man gezielt nur einen Kapitel hören will, aber man hört dann mal ein Stück und denkt sich, ok, davon habe ich jetzt genug gehört, lass mal eins weiterspringen, weil ich habe gerade nicht mehr viel Zeit oder was auch immer. Kapitelmarken sind wirklich mit das beste Feature. Dazu kommen aber dann auch andere Sachen, die heute fast jeder moderne Podcast kleint hat. Max hat es vorhin schon ein bisschen erwähnt, die Abspielgeschwindigkeit erhöhen. Ich glaube, Max, du gehörst zu der Fraktion, die schon lange keinen Podcast mehr auf normaler Geschwindigkeit gehört haben.
Ja, total, total. 1.8. ist in der Regel die Abspielgeschwindigkeit meines Vertrauens und Stille natürlich raus reduziert.
Genau, Trim Silence heißt es bei Pocketcast hier vor mir. Ich gucke gerade drauf. Damit schneidet der Podcast-Klient automatisch ein bisschen Sprechpausen raus.
Bist du gerade in deinen Statistiken drin, Frank? Wollen wir mal vergleichen, wie viel wir gespart haben durch Varia und Speak?
Ich hör tatsächlich noch nicht so lange über Pocketcast. Bei mir ist es nur 1 Tag, 6 Stunden und 8 Minuten. Und ich hab Trim Silence im Moment sogar aus.
Okay, also ich habe 10 Tage und 10 Stunden allein, die herausgezogen wurden aus meinem Podcast. Durch dieses Feature und durch die erhöhte Abspielgeschwindigkeit habe ich 61 Tage und 7 Stunden Podcast gespart.
Und jetzt rechnet mal diese 10 Tage in Schlusskonferenz. Dann wisst ihr, wie viele Schlusskonferenz es nicht gäbe, hätte Max diese Funktion nicht. Okay, es ist eine Milchmädchenrechnung, aber... Ja, aber da kommt eben noch ganz vieles anderes dazu. Da kommen zum Beispiel bei Pocketcast dazu, dass ihr euch eigene Playlisten zusammenstellen könnt nach Themen oder keine Ahnung. Ich habe da so automatische Listen, die mir nur die neuesten Podcasts der letzten Woche gibt. Dann habe ich eine andere Liste, da landen nur zeitlose Podcasts drauf, die ich eben nicht zeitnah hören muss und so weiter. Dann gibt es eine Liste, die heißt Zeitsprung, die dürfte eigentlich gar nicht mehr so heißen. Die Kollegen haben nämlich ihren Namen geändert. Aber da gibt es eine eigene Liste, weil ich da auf jeden Fall mal alle alten Folgen nachhören wollte, die ich noch nicht gehört habe und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt ganz tolle Features. Vor allem die Möglichkeiten, die man zum Beispiel unter iOS hat, mit Audio auf verschiedenen Geräten ausgeben und so ist da noch mal ein ganzes Stück besser wie mit Spotify.
Also das ist tatsächlich in fast allen Apps besser als bei Spotify, weil Spotify das auch nicht gebraucht hat bisher, weil Spotify anders funktioniert. Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ich möchte mir keine neue App installieren, um von Spotify wegzuwechseln, jedes Smartphone hat per se eine Podcast-App drauf. Entweder ist das Google Podcast oder es ist Apple Podcasts. Da kann man jetzt auch argumentieren, dass das nicht die perfekten Apps sind. Also gerade Google Podcasts, ich hab's jetzt ehrlich gesagt schon länger nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Das ist auch bei Apple nicht mehr vorinstalliert.
Ach guck, das dürfen sie nicht mehr...
Nicht mehr alle Apps, die Default-App sind, sind vorinstalliert, aber es ist kostenlos und einen Klick im App-Store entfernt. Und es gibt tatsächlich heute auch keinen Grund, mehr irgendeine App auf iOS nicht zu installieren, wenn man mal von Kosten absieht.
Genau. Und wenn jemand ein Genau-Drink-Spiel gemacht hat, meine Güte, dann hat er jetzt schon drei Promille. Tut mir leid, ich weiß nicht, was mit mir los ist, wie oft ich jetzt schon dieses Wort gesagt habe. Aber ihr tut uns einen Gefallen damit. Und wir glauben auch, dass es für euch auch Vorteile haben kann, in eine, in Anführungszeichen, richtige Podcast-App zu wechseln. Vielleicht lernt ihr dann das Medium auch noch mal auf eine andere Art und Weise schätzen und lieben, zumindest für Frank und mich. Und wir sind ja wirklich Hardcore-Podcast-Hörer. Also ich höre glaube ich nicht seit 2008, aber 2011 oder 2012 dürfte ich wahrscheinlich angefangen haben, irgendwann mit Not Safe For Work in die Podcast-Welt einzusteigen. Und dann wart ich in ihr verschwunden und nie wieder gesehen, wie man an meiner extremen Podcast-Nutzung jetzt sehen kann. Es hat einen Grund, warum wir uns nie im Leben vorstellen könnten, so etwas wie Spotify zu wechseln. Und das hat eben auch mit Usability zu tun, gar nicht mit den anderen Problematiken, die wir vorher thematisiert haben. Also sprich, lasst euch einfach von zwei Podcast-Experten empfehlen. Probiert mal Podcast-Apps aus oder andere Nutzungswege, die nicht Spotify sind. Es ist nicht zu eurem Nachteil. Es gibt kostenlose Apps, es gibt Apps, für die man einen kleinen Betrag zahlt, aber es gibt einen erheblichen Mehrwert. Und gleichzeitig tut er eben auch etwas für alle Podcast-ProduzentInnen, wie eben auch Frank und mich.
Genau, und lass mich noch eins einwerfen, bevor ich es vergesse. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es weißt, aber gibt es bei Spotify eigentlich Show-Notes, wenn die Links funktionieren?
Ja, wenn wir bei Spotify Nutzer wären. Ich weiß es nicht, ob sie es irgendwann eingeführt haben.
Darum an dieser Stelle, rasenfunk.de/umfragewirdeine Weiterleitung sein zu unserer Umfrage. Wenn ihr den Link in der Beschreibung nicht klicken könnt oder gar nichts seht, macht euch keinen Kopf. rasenfunk.de/umfragerichteich nachher gleich noch ein, bevor wir die Sendung veröffentlichen. Und falls ihr diese Sendung irgendwann später hört, wir nehmen jetzt, wir haben es keine dazu gesagt, aber wir nehmen jetzt im Dezember 2020 auf, irgendwann wird die Umfrage geschlossen sein oder der Link nicht mehr funktionieren. Also wenn am Anfang vielleicht keine 2 mehr steht bei der Jahreszahl, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass es nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ihr könnt aber jederzeit Feedback schicken, auch unabhängig von dieser Umfrage, an team.rasenfunk.de Genau, das ist auch noch wichtig. Ja, schon und bald, würde ich in große Anführungszeichen setzen. Ich möchte dann noch einen Hörtipp geben. Wir haben jetzt ein paar Probleme, die wir mit Spotify haben angerissen. Wir haben es nicht geschafft, wollten es auch, glaube ich, nicht das All umfassend zu beschäftigen. Das hat auch die Sendung nicht geschafft, die ich euch empfehlen möchte. Aber trotzdem ist es ein sehr gutes Gespräch geworden. Deutschlandfunk Kultur hat in der Podcast-Reihe Breitband ein Gespräch von Dirk von Gehlen und Sandro Schröder zusammen mit dem Moderator Philipp Bansel geführt, eben genau über diese Frage, was macht der sogenannte Plattform Kapitalismus mit dem Podcast-Bereich? Das war ein sehr interessantes Gespräch, wo viele Dinge, die wir jetzt auch nur so angeschnitten haben, nochmal anders besprochen werden. Und wir haben noch ein paar Aspekte ergänzt, die in dieser Sendung nicht vorkommen. Denn natürlich, sie durfte nur eine Stunde lang sein, denn sie wurde ja im Deutschlandfunk, im Radio ausgestrahlt. Und wo kämen wir denn hin, wenn man einfach so lange redet, wie er ein Thema braucht? Frank, das wäre ja völlig irre. Nein, also... Aber diese Sendung, die können wir euch ans Ohr legen, wenn euch das Thema generell interessiert, weil es da eben noch mal ein paar ganz interessante grundsätzliche Überlegungen gibt zur Gestalt des Internets, wie es da ist. Und Spotify ist ja beileibe nicht die erste Plattform, die sich ein Monopol erschafft. Und man kann eben einfach inzwischen Rückschlüsse ziehen, aus der Art und Weise, wie Facebook sich etabliert hat, wie YouTube sich etabliert hat, eben bezüglich gewisser Mechanismen, die eigentlich unvermarktbar scheinen, auch aus Plattformbetreiber Sicht. Und wie es dann bei Spotify kommen wird. Also vielleicht so manches, was wir jetzt dann so ein bisschen angekündigt haben, wo ihr vielleicht die Augenbraue gehoben habt und euch gedacht habt, woher wollen sie das denn genau wissen, dass sich das entwickelt. Wir erleben das nicht zum ersten Mal, Frank und ich. Und das wird in dieser Sendung auch ganz gut aufgefangen. Die wird natürlich auch in den Show Notes verlinkt. Und wenn ihr sie nicht klicken könnt, dann seid ihr definitiv in der falschen Podcast-App unterwegs, liebe Leute. rasenfunk.de/umfrage. Bitte macht mit, wir freuen uns sehr auf euer Feedback. Wir hoffen, dass ihr ein schönes Rasenfunk-Jahr hattet. Bei all den Besonderheiten, die dieses Jahr hatte. Immer bei der Verabschiedung fange ich an wieder zu stolpern. Und wir hoffen vor allem, ich denke, da spreche ich auch in deinem Sinne, Frank, dass ihr alle gesund geblieben seid, dass ihr alle gut durch den bisherigen Teil dieser Pandemie gekommen seid und dass ihr weiter die Kraft habt, euch an alle Regeln zu halten und eure Mitmenschen und vor allem diejenigen, die Risikogruppen angehören, zu schützen. Bleibt dran, ihr seid nicht allein. Wir halten uns auch an alle Regeln. Führt weiter ganz brav eure Kontakt-Tagebücher. Irgendwann kommt der Frühling und der Sommer. Es wird besser werden. Und wenn uns Johnny Dietmar Hopp rettet, dann macht es eben jemand anderes.
Was für ein Abschluss.
Ich würde jetzt gerne anfangen zu singen, aber das verstehen dann sowieso nur alle 93 Hörerinnen. Aber in diesem Sinne glaube ich, können wir doch hier zumachen. Frank, ich danke dir sehr, dass du mit dabei warst. Ich danke dir, dass du die Umleitung von rasenfunk.de/umfrageeingerichtethaben wirst nach dieser Sendung. Und dass wir zweimal wieder sprechen konnten in diesem Mittelpass, in diesem langen Terminalpass, in dieser halbfeldflanken Sendung. Es war schön mal wieder mit dir zu sprechen.
Vielen Dank auch an dich.
Genau, möchte ich da ein letztes Mal sagen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es war wirklich ein besonders herausforderndes Jahr. Danke, dass ihr mit dabei war, dass ihr uns treu geblieben seid. Wir sind sehr gespannt auf eure Rückmeldungen, auf die Umfrage und auch auf diese Sendung. Unterstützt den Rasenfunk, empfiehlt ihn weiter, wenn ihr mögt. Hört in Elfleben, solltet ihr es noch nicht getan haben. Und wenn ja, dann möchte ich wissen, warum zur Hölle habt ihr das noch nicht gemacht. Das ist mein Lebenswerk. Das ist genauso wie der Rasenfunk. Also in diesem Sinne habt eine gute Zeit und bleibt bitte gesund. Wir hören uns wieder im Jahr 2021. Bis dahin macht's gut.